[Music]
nobody has seen a wormhole nobody has
produced One nobody knows if it is just
the beautiful moth but without a
physical reality
well we'll take the world's best quantum
computer and see if we can map that into
building the Wormhole and then it became
just at the edge of what's possible
I think the discovery of the Hicks which
came about 10 years ago was up to that
point the most exciting point of my
entire career this to me is equally
exciting it can begin to explore Quantum
states that are very hard to realize in
nature directly
now the Wormhole becomes traversable it
opens you really can go through
foreign
[Music]
begins in 1935 when Einstein wrote a
paper with Rosen where the first time
Einstein Rosen Bridges appear and these
are bridges that connect to seemingly
unconnectable pieces of space-time
ER Einstein and Rosen they pointed out
that solutions to general relativity
allowed for two black holes which are
connected but with a kind of bridge what
we call a wormhole
but that Wormhole has the property of
being non-traversable
Wormhole is a very unstable passage it
opens and it closes and it gets Celtic
and it gets destroyed very fast
so Einstein when he proposed The
Wormhole he was very frustrated because
you couldn't actually go through a
wormhole and he was able to realize that
himself and so what good is a wormhole
if you can't put anything through it and
it turns out that that's because he
wasn't putting in the quantum physics
1935 same year another paper the epr
paper which is Einstein Rosen Podolski
DPR is about quantum entanglement and
what Einstein called spooky action at a
distance something he was not happy with
and tangerman is this property the
subatomic particles they are Partners
even if you take them apart and take
them at the other edge of the universe
they hold information if you measure the
wine you know what the other will be so
entanglement is the strong correlation
Einstein didn't like quantum mechanics
and this made it very challenging for
him to understand how to reconcile
quantum physics and gravitational
physics physicists want to understand as
much as they can about how the universe
works so it has been a challenge which
has occupied many scientists over
decades to understand better how quantum
physics and general relativity fit
together into a coherent picture
Einstein's dream was to figure out how
to connect them
those two papers there was no reason to
think at the time or for decades
afterward that they had anything to do
with one another apart from there being
some authors in common
and then comes 2013
maldacena and Lani Sasuke they say ER
equals epr they are the same this is
very daring wormholes an entanglement
are the same thing
that was totally unexpected one of them
has to do with general relativity one of
them has to do with quantum mechanics
didn't seem like I had anything to do
with each other a lot of times in
physics you can have two different
descriptions of the same thing but it's
just sort of a remapping of the same
physics and we call that a duality
[Music]
the basic idea was that when you have
quantum entanglement between two for
black holes necessarily there will be a
wormhole connecting them
it's like saying gravity equals quantum
mechanics if we want to say it in a
simplified way
so there we have a picture of quantum
gravity
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we have this dictionary that relates
gravitational phenomena to ordinary
quantum physics you can tackle the same
physics from these two different angles
and that's the most concrete path
forward we have in building a full
theory of quantum gravity
[Music]
Sun an experiment in a black hole and
and validate that so instead we can ask
can there be Quantum systems whose dual
description looks like wormholes
I think it might have actually been
during a talk by Juan Mama Messina about
the R equals epr so I started to wonder
to myself could traversable wormholes
exist right and people thought it was
fascinating as an exotic configuration
of space-time but I think many people
probably suspected that it could work so
we saw that it could one of the magical
things about quantum mechanics is you
can actually have negative energy and
this allows you to do things that you
would have thought otherwise were
impossible
but Daniel I first showed was that if
you introduce what's known as a negative
energy shock wave you can support your
Wormhole and get something from one end
and have it come out the other
now I'm an experimentalist so I look at
that I do all right what can I do about
that
we were thinking we have the ability to
do things in Quantum in the laboratory
we're physicists so could we imagine
actually doing something with wormholes
it almost occurred to us immediately
that we should be using the best quantum
system that we know how to manipulate
and what is that it's a quantum computer
[Music]
quantum computers speak a different
language than the ordinary language of
bits a bit you look at it okay it's a
zero or one that's it
the correlations among qubits are richer
and a lot more interesting than
correlations among bits it's this
language of quantum entanglement
and so there's a world out there that's
extravagant Quantum orals which we just
haven't been able to explore
[Music]
I've worked on a few projects at Google
Quantum and got to get to know the
device a bit and the Google Device is
the best quantum computer that that is
around
all the magic happens in this little
chip you have the the actual qubits as
these superconducting pieces of aluminum
and that's where the entanglement
happens
we had the access to the Google quantum
computer I came over with Maria and
Daniel and Joe and we were like we have
a proposal to try to you know observe a
wormhole on the the quantum computer and
to put the proposal together it was
obvious that these are the people
in physics you have to have the courage
of your own convictions and you say well
maybe it won't work the way that I
thought but we'll learn something by
trying and that's really the attitude we
had going into this I don't think we
really thought it was going to work but
we thought we would learn a lot by
seeing how far you could get they didn't
say you're crazy let's do something else
they said okay you're crazy let's do it
[Music]
you can use the holographic Duality to
create the quantum version of the system
we look Instead at this set of entangled
qubits and we evolve it in a way that
has exactly the same physics as the
gravitational wormhole
and so in quantum computer we can
directly send a qubit from one side of
the Wormhole and watch it come out the
other
if you take the physical system that
theoretical physicists say this is a
wormhole and you work out pencil and
paper so how good of a quantum computer
do I need you get an answer that's like
a quantum computer 10 years from now it
looks hopeless
but we thought let's try
all right well so we are in our gq2 lab
and then the controlled signals actually
are produced in this racks sitting next
to the cryostat when you try to just run
a wormhole as the theorists have
prepared it on a quantum computer you
find that you need to implement this
very large system so that's big that's a
big fat problem
I cannot put it on an experiment
[Music]
and so we have to do is we have to do it
because it's called course braiding so
you want to preserve certain features in
this case gravitational features while
throwing away all the unnecessary
components
we knew we needed to go to a smaller
system size and so we were kind of
banging our head against it for a year
or something
and then finally you you come up with a
weird idea that that might work
the idea of rewriting it as the neural
network is something that's kind of out
there and that's like it's it's a weird
idea because you usually don't think of
physical wormholes as neural networks
the Wormhole itself that has like these
many parameters that we treat as
neuroelectric weights we then have a
data set that we're going to train on
which is the Dynamics that we want to
observe that correspond to wormhole
so it sounds like a generic machine
learning problem now and we can just
like plug it straight into the machine
learning toolbox I propose the the idea
and tried it out the original system has
210 terms
the machine learning managed to keep all
this intact while making a much smaller
system
it's still baby enough that it fits on
the crib
that was the the kind of first moment
where like it might be possible you know
I saw this whole Wormhole thing we've
been talking about for two years like
maybe you can actually do it
[Music]
at probably like two in the morning I I
was running these Quantum circuits we're
looking for a peak that's the qubit
making it Through the Wormhole I'm
watching the data as it comes out
there's a little bit of a noisy Peak at
first I was I was like this is probably
just a noise artifact but as the data
kept coming and that the peak kept
getting clearer it was like this is this
is a wormhole I think I just saw one and
so I was usually like sending it off to
Maria and the others like I think we've
got Wormhole guys
he said it's there I said no kidding
he's there it was not
it was nuts
what happens is the qubits of the Google
quantum computer are making a little bit
of extra space and that's our wormhole
thank you
a pulse of negative energy falls into
the wormhole
the Wormhole becomes traversable it
opens
it opens you put a qubit through one
side of the wormhole
Cubit is now in the interior of the
Swarm hole
that information will actually spread
over the entire Quantum system
this spread of calm information could
become shared by many particles in the
form of quantum entanglement
and then rather remarkably it has to
refocus as a single qubit
and then as the Wormhole is closing the
qubit is exiting
I was absolutely astounded I I thought
we would get maybe a few steps towards a
real Wormhole and a real quantum
computer and I never really believed
that we get all the way to something
that that was
reality like reactions that they want to
hack the machine
I told my brother in Greece on the phone
and he squealed and he said are you
destroying the world what are you doing
then it was difficult to explain to him
that nobody is in danger from this
wormhole
on the processor if we had a Quantum
sensitive iron looked in there we
wouldn't see a ripple of space-time we
would see the physics that we expect
from the gravity point of view and from
the quantum point of view
so if that is the case then we're making
contact between Quantum and gravity
that's been the Holy Grail of my whole
career is to understand quantum gravity
and the things that go with it like
wormholes we are studying quantum
gravity literally from the ground up
arrived to summon this
[Music]
here we are almost a century later I
wish he was alive to see this because I
would like to know what you would say
well on Einstein has said
uh he would have said ER equals epr I
told you I knew that in 1935.
but he didn't
I think this is concrete experimental
evidence for ER equals epr
the vector is pointing right from the
experimental point of view
this is a confirmation a direct
exploration of this connection between
quantum entanglement on the one hand and
the way space is knit together and holds
itself together
as Google builds more and more capable
quantum computers we will eventually be
able to get this into a regime where we
don't even know how to predict what's
going to happen and I think we're going
to have hundreds of my fellow physicists
now writing papers about all the other
things you can think about doing now now
that we've sort of got this door a
little bit open
and as always in physics when you are
able to explore a new frontier there
will be discoveries that weren't
anticipated just like when you build a
more powerful accelerator to study
particle collisions or more powerful
telescope to look at the more distant
Universe a more powerful quantum
computer will be able to study highly
entangled matter that we've never been
able to look at before
I think in the next 20 years there are
going to be a lot of fun for fundamental
physics being very close with Quantum
we're gonna learn a lot
there's so many questions that one could
explore using these ideas and I think
most exciting are the questions that we
can't yet pose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]